get ready to float a little bit time for
the uplifted eight
i'll share the stories that bring you
some joy in your day jamie wax is here
vlad's on vacation lift us up jamie i'm
gonna leave you jamie as best i can this
this will lift you this is really
wonderful we've got a video that should
give you hope for the next generation
watch this
oh they trying the neighborhood kid
trying to teach my baby how to uh ride
the bike with no training wheels and i
think it's just the cutest thing
that is so cute
it is the cutest thing that voice
belongs to tambria curry uh the
clarksville tennessee mom looked out her
window and saw her seven-year-old son
mike kell riding a bike with no training
wheels with some help from his friends
in the neighborhood she says it just
goes to show it's okay to ask for a
little help sometimes that's right seems
like a recurring theme today
i love that that seems like a great
block
don't you remember when we all learned
to ride a bike it seems like i'll never
get the hang of it but it's so nice to
see little kids helping other little
kids and he'll remember that for the
rest of his life
so what i was going to say so last month
teaching my baby how to ride a bike that
was a good uplift james we need the kids
to guide us sometime you're right
i know especially you always think about
the news how we started this first hour
it's just first 20 minutes it's just one
thing after another after another that i
was actually grateful to hear about a
dangerous heat wave yeah because so much
was so heavy so we needed your story
today yes let's lift it up a little
thank you so much